you
so I toes in front of Conda yesterday
her car Chester undelete Zimmerman
explains that the first Toyota AYGO came
out in 2005 it held its own with its
nine competitors at the time but now
there are 20 Toyota wants to attract
young buyers
it's hoping to do this with the help of
its unique design though the igo is the
result of a cooperation between toyota
pujo and sit when the design is
definitely inspired by Japanese
tradition and styles but typically for
this market segment the car is efficient
nimble and versatile in the eye goes
updated version these virtues have been
enhanced even more
I'm angle goofy Andre says he likes the
I go because it's designed for the city
he says the steering is smooth and the
turning circle is tight so it's always
easy to drive countless customization
options let customers tailor the I go
into their dream car the various color
combinations are rich in contrasts the X
is unique spoiler since the I go apart
from its rivals
the pattern can also be found on the
rear we need to have a a very dynamic
and expressive design to stand up so
putting this in mind we started with a
kind of a Japanese culture like pop
culture or Japanese manga or Japanese
kabuki which we call j factors so if you
can see in this maybe you can see this
front bumper like an ex I would say it's
a mixed-blood combination which we think
we achieve a very new design the eye
goes interior is also attractive and
rich in contrasts customers can choose
the color combinations themselves
everything is very user friendly and
comfortable
leather seats cost twelve hundred euros
more the trunk is small also typical for
this class a lot of eyes of anything
aundrea explains that he usually adjust
the steering wheel when he gets into a
new car so I can see the instruments
despite his height but he doesn't have
to do that with the I go because the
instruments are on the steering column
itself is some shampoo cleanness once
the idea is to mention all when it comes
to engines the options are more limited
the three-cylinder 1.0 litre 68
horsepower engine is now even more
efficient it climbs from 0 to 100 km/h
in 14.2 seconds fuel consumption is
rated at just 4.1 litres per 100
kilometers and customers who want to
save on gas can opt for a greener
version for 950 euros more and then fuel
consumption drops to 3.8 liters
I all guns Andre says sticker prices
don't differ that much in the segment
most city cars have a starting price of
10,000 euros in Germany a three-cylinder
engine and about the same amount of
space but Toyota stands out because of
its design and that's what we'll draw
the customers APPA gothenburg toyota has
brought out a uniquely designed car and
doesn't want to imitate the Europeans
but the igo is made in the Czech
Republic with its new starting price of
nine thousand nine hundred fifty euros
in Germany the updated version is on par
with its rivals and will attract many
buyers especially those at the start of
their driving careers
starting with its very first series
production model the 356 porsche has put
out college sports cars in open and
close top versions with the roof custom
designed for each model and purpose
convertible roadster target and others
one out of three 911s built in the past
50 years has been a convertible or
target the open-top boxster and the
hardtop cayman are neck and neck and
sales Porsche roof engineer feel examine
says the car maker develops each top
specially for the model and contracts
the supplier to make the top and
cooperation with Porsche in Europe the
porsche 356 convertible quickly made its
name as a fast and dependable sports car
but in the united states the man grew
for a lower-priced relatively purist
version that led to the creation of yet
another cult Porsche the 356 speedster
Portia roof design dirty motion sit ski
explains that you had to get into the
356 speedster to open the fastener and
then push the top back into its
compartment by hand protection hunt not
hidden in the obligee be big in the
1960s it was manual today it's fully
electric in the new Boxster the roof
goes down at the push of a button fully
automatically while driving or standing
still hustling the Boxster's top opens
and closes in less than 10 seconds when
Portia first conceived the 911 an
open-top version was taken for granted
but indications were coming from the
united states that convertibles without
roll bars would no longer be licensed
for American roads that necessitated the
development of an entirely new safety
concept the result was the target
equipped with a roll bar what's hard
Felix airman remembers that on the 1970
target the top was still manual the
driver had to remove it fold it up and
stow it away in the trunk follow him
perform for stolen in early 2014 Porsche
unveiled the latest and most spectacular
generation of the 911 targa it combines
the early models extravagant charm with
today's comfort and technology
hebei consignor felix chairman explains
the roof is based on the original panel
boat up toward the front our too hard
fabric covered roof panels that fold
down under the top compartment lid
beneath the rear glass wraparound window
it takes 19 seconds for the top to open
and it only works with the car standing
still Porsche use new materials to
further improve heat and noise
insulation a main focus from the start
was to enhance the convenience of
operation
I'm going on by cop Felix Herman says
fully automatic roofs are available for
the 993 convertible but the driver has
to get out to fasten down the cover
manually for the latest 911 convertible
Porsche expanded the targus automatic
panel boat up to four panels
but Lauren Felix chairman says the
current top is a completely new design
by portion it's a panel boat up with a
continuous fabric cover supported by
four hard panels it opens fully
automatically within 13 seconds using
two hydraulic cylinders just still stop
it I have some fried sensical closely
all porsche convertibles have at least
one thing in common the intensive
enjoyment that comes from driving a
sports car with the top down
Audi has launched its first plug-in
hybrid model called the a3 sportback
e-tron it combines the power of a 1.4
liter TFSI engine and an electric motor
for an overall 150 horsepower the Audi
a3 sportback e-tron can reach 100 km/h
in just 7.6 seconds and go on to a
maximum speed of 222 km/h an electric
mode the five-door compact car is a bit
slower but it can still reach a maximum
speed of 130 km/h opal has upgraded its
movano utility vehicle with more
efficient twin turbo engines the new
model has 120 kilowatts that's 9
kilowatts more than the last version yet
it consumes 1.5 liters less diesel per
100 kilometers that means fuel
consumption of 7.2 litres per 100
kilometers and co2 emissions of 188 g/km
and Germany this version of the movano
starts at just over 35,000 euros
cars are tested for extreme driving
conditions like the wet surface at the
driving camp in pok fert austria
cutting-edge technology can be applied
to coping with almost any driving
conditions when it comes to handling one
key factor is all-wheel drive
that's cuz I'm scooter communications
head pike from best and boastful
explains that the entire off road
segment is growing but we ought to
distinguish between cars that look like
off-roaders and real off-roaders either
way sports utility vehicles are
currently in high demand so Skoda is
expanding its SUV range even more than
cavortin of massive item skoda offers a
number of models with all-wheel drive
the Yeti Octavia and superb both and
sedans and station wagons all-wheel
drive has advantages both on and off the
road
with my god safe driving instructor
Christian Tyson says all wheel drive
gives the driver a greater safety margin
the power is distributed equally to all
four wheels with front or rear wheel
drive the wheels might start spinning
but all wheel drive provides greater
traction and better surface grip the
Yeti outdoor 4 by 4 SUV more than lives
up to its robust off-road look doing
surprisingly well at handling fairly
rugged terrain the getty's
fifth-generation haldex transmission
comes into its own away from paved
surfaces the power is distributed to the
wheels as needed to achieve the best
grip even if it's only on one single
wheel
the next test is driving down slopes
most 40 mind before Christian teason
starts downhill he has to push the
off-road button and inched ahead
cautiously until he knows which way to
steer then he lets the vehicle do the
work that means he could actually lit up
on the brakes and gas and the car will
roll gently down the hill all the driver
has to do is stay on the road the
vehicle does all the rest unless the
month of thoughts that got us I
extinguish in its off-road driving mode
the Yeti outdoor 4 by 4 is highly
versatile its cross-country mobility is
enhanced by its 18 centimeter clearance
a hill hold control assistant and the
all-wheel-drive the Yeti can handle
grades of almost 20 degrees in dec
christian teason stresses that taking
slopes does still take patience the
driver has to proceed slowly keeping a
fine sense for the surface and the cars
motion he's amazed at how this little
SUV off-roader can take steep sideways
angles when he feels the vehicle slide
he can compensate just a little and ease
it down the hill welcome over to the any
outdoor four-by-fours electronic
differential lock provides extra support
going cross-country
young Christians heading into a road
shaped almost like a trench he weaves
from side to side putting the weight on
one side of the vehicle and leaving the
other in the air the off-road driving
though the electronic differential lock
keeps the car moving even with one wheel
off the road here again the
all-wheel-drive supported by high-tech
does the job yamaki missile all the
driver has to do is point the car the
right way and it manages to get their
accompanying goes unseen scoot is four
by four models are well equipped to deal
with all kinds of terrain and road
conditions whether on the way to work
school or a long extreme adventure
holiday
ziyad my test driver Christoph Bauer
says he's dreamed of driving a
Lamborghini Countach since he was a
child in the early 1970s it was the
fastest car in the road with a top speed
of 300 kilometers and a v12 engine with
375 horsepower it can go from zero to a
hundred klicks in under six seconds
though the gas pedals not that sensitive
he says so a typical race car you need a
firm hold on the wheel and a heavy foot
on the gas at 3,000 revs that starts to
wake up he says at 4,000 it starts to
roar and upwards of 5,500 all hell
breaks loose
the Countach is definitely a looker just
one point zero seven meters high it's
guaranteed to turn heads the fastest way
to draw a crowd is to have the Countach
spread its wings the only concession to
the driver is the air conditioning there
are a few other creature comforts the
v12 4-liter engine steals the show
when the revs tip 8,000 the Countach
hits its limit of 375 horsepower but the
car never reaches its top speed of 300
kilometers but in 1974 288 kilometers an
hour was enough for it to be called the
fastest car on the road Christophe Bauer
says it's a good thing the air
conditioning works so well because the
windows don't they only open a cracky
says there's not much luxury here
generally says the dashboard fittings
look like they've been bought up at a
local accessory shop but then the
Countach is strengths lie elsewhere he
says to take a lot Eden it was
have a good but is not to come to Havana
be returned
designer Marcello Gandini said he wanted
to create a car that would cause
onlookers mouths to hang open
Isaac Christophe says the car is the
ultimate challenge he thinks his left
leg will be aching tomorrow from working
the clash inside the cars not so hot he
says but outside it's a sensation the
burtoni design studio really created
something unparalleled especially when
you think the car was unveiled in 1971
production started in 1973 he says and
continued until nineteen ninety and it
still looks futuristic today someone
just asked him if this is the latest
Lambo he says Marcello Gandini was
definitely ahead of his time alveston
water on it and the engine was the first
to be installed longitudinally he says
which is now standard for all Italian
super sports cars and the engine doesn't
just look good he says it's sounds
sensational a clink oh then zatsune a
12-cylinder engines are a long-standing
tradition at Lamborghini in 1964 the
Gran Turismo 350gt was the first to take
the road with its 270 horsepower
overnight the Lamborghini legend was
born
in 1966 the Lamborghini Miura followed
it had a mid-engine layout which set a
new trend for future super sports cars
the Mira is still considered one of the
most beautiful sports cars of all time
the extreme wedge like shape of the
countach on the other hand came as quite
a shock particularly the final series
with its conspicuous vents for cooling
the engine with just two protruding
cooler vents the flowing lines of the
first Countach series were definitely
more harmonious after the first test
drives the radiators located behind the
cockpit had to be repositioned
vertically that was the only way to keep
the temperature of the engine which was
positioned in front of the rear axle
under control
the engineers were less fussy about fuel
consumption the 12-cylinder engine with
its six Weber carburetors is a real gas
guzzler the van Cousteau says any
Countach driver will be a regular at the
local gas station as the car consumes at
least 20 liters per 100 kilometers and
can use a whole lot more but the good
thing he says is that you can fill it up
from both sides the two tanks are linked
with a fuel equalizer but the process
takes forever he says this is a hostage
vodka [ __ ] seguin yard
the car requires premium grade gasoline
and holds a total of 120 litres of fuel
in all so filling up the car in both
sides at the same time doesn't just look
good it saves a lot of time
the twin tanks help to balance the car
and keep its center of gravity stable
thanks to the aluminum body work the
countach only weighs 1,370 five kilos
which together with the racing car
chassis means it handles well on curves
it'd be no good for people with a
bouffant hairstyle says Christophe in
fact everything's a bit cramped that's
the disadvantage of a mid-engine layout
he says you have to share the space with
the engine transmission all the
mechanical parts but it's definitely
wide not so ideal for narrow mountain
roads better for the highway but great
on Ben's he says Topsy off ojala Phillip
the cars greatest weakness zero rearview
visibility is also less of a problem on
the highway this is mosey
hola bola
devoir stop it this must be the
sturdiest golf ever says our cart
estimate is correct made of granite it
becomes a symbol for the annual GTI meet
invitin it's on Lake Vertu's a tamato
says he's here to discover what GTI fans
are up to and what there is to see I'm
duelin guess two years or so zangum on
Vasquez Oh Susan get lots of GTI's at
any rate and their fans many of whom
come here year after year
p hi scallops where's the GTI capital
Montes asked about the selectmen's
that's certainly true for one weekend a
year when over 100,000 VW fans gather in
the small village in Austria they bring
their cars to even if it means pushing
them
since 2006 VW has been the main sponsor
of the event the automaker shows off the
latest prototypes like this wolfsburg
edition Golf GTI built by trainees the
city of Wolfsburg may not be much to
look at but the car named after it is a
real eye-catcher lanka says the needs no
longer just for gold fans almost all of
the VW Group's brands are here he likes
Audi stand which resembles a pit length
so what do these girls think buddy
medicines are not very talkative montes
decides to go and have a look at Audi a3
clubsport quattro concept car that's
celebrating its world premiere here
based on the a3 sedan Audi's Quattro
division has created a sport version of
the car that's lower wider and faster
than the most powerful series production
model you know i dis.n define solar
vaguer from Audi Quattro says people
here are active in the tuning scene and
tinker with their cars themselves so
they know how much work and attention to
detail go into the show cars and he says
here you get a feel for trends in the
tuning scene and the exchange which can
be a bit crazy but also expert is
something you really only find
advertised a GV g do it I'm feel to see
and because many of the guests here
spend the night at campgrounds Audi has
brought along some useful gear a tent
that can be blown up quickly and
attached to the car this initial version
can be fastened to a q3
the latest offering from Spanish
automakers Ayotte might not be so
practical but it is definitely flashing
its cup stir combines elements of a
roadster a small car and a sports car
that cup size i need this rib says the
cups there is an emotional
interpretation of se hace beats ax Leon
cup racer and a convertible he says they
wanted to show what they could do here
people could also play card table tennis
an interesting twist on pong the coke
video game of the 1980s
nearby oscoda visitors brave a go-kart
course on mini quads and capture the
action using a helmet camera
guests can also view the city jet part
small car part roadster it too was
designed and built by trainees not to be
missed are the daring drivers who
perform acrobatic maneuvers with their
vehicles and really burn rubber
volkswagen Supervisory Board Chairman
Ferdinand peeche was also on hand to
thank lighten its for granting him
honorary citizenship for the amber gosh
of life knits was happy to show his
gratitude for the 20 million euros in
business the GTI me generates each year
but for visitors it's all about seeing
and being seen the flatbed of a midsize
pickup is the perfect place to party ok
Marcus says here in to 33rd GTI meet
he's standing on an Amerind pick up he
claims it only goes 100 kilometers an
hour so it took the guys eight hours to
get here sigh Modio cannot say he says
it only goes 90 kilometers an hour ok ok
90 motto says how could he have thought
otherwise but he says it's fun up here
and suggest they keep on party
you